dear prime minister antonio costa
ladies and gentlemen good morning i am
delighted
to address you at the digital assembly
and indeed
this year's digital assembly is very
timely
not even three months ago we presented
our vision
for europe's digital transformation by
it is about where we want to go and
who we want to be we call
it our digital compass it fits well
that we are holding this digital
assembly
in portugal today as a seafaring nation
generations of portuguese explorers
knew how to sail across uncharted waters
the monument on the bank of the tesho in
lisbon
reminds us of the most important ones
prince henry the navigator
who discovered madeira and the azores
vasco da gama who found the sea route to
india
so i think it is fair to say in portugal
you know well how to navigate
and we are lucky to have you as council
presidency
at this point in time but seriously
when you navigate you do not only need a
compass
you also need a plan forward
our digital compass is about all that
like a compass with north south east and
west
our european strategy has four cardinal
points
digital skills infrastructures
business and in e-government
to master the challenges of the digital
age we must make progress on all
forefronts
so first of all skills
by 2030 we want for example
20 million i.t specialists to be
employed in the european union
second infrastructures
by 2030 we won gigabit connectivity
for all households and 5g in
all cities and villages
third the digital transformation of
businesses
by 2030 three out of four companies
should use cloud big data and ai
and fourth digital public services
by 2030 all eu citizens
should have access to electronic health
records
and by the way speaking of health today
is an
important day for our eu digital covet
certificate our eu gateway
goes live more than 20 member states
have tested it successfully
and it will allow to verify all
certificates across
the continent everyone who is fully
vaccinated
or has a negative test result
or has recovered from the virus can
get the european certificate it's for
free
and it must be recognized everywhere in
the european union
it is a tangible example of how people
benefit from
digital progress in the european union
but of course it also matters how we are
doing things
the european union certificate is a
prime example
of digital tools that represent our
values
the eu values privacy
so no personal data will be exchanged or
retained
the european union is inclusive
so whoever is not vaccinated
can get a digital certificate for test
or recovery whoever does not have a
smartphone
can get it on paper
with the certificate we want to help
people to move
freely in times of pandemic and this is
why it will only be in place for one
year
europe is a front runner here and
can set standards at the global level
or let me give you another example
we want to offer to europeans a new
digital
identity an identity
that ensures trust and protects users
online we are about to present our
proposal
it will allow everyone to control their
identity
online and to interact with governments
and businesses across the european union
nobody should be forced to give more
data away
than is necessary for the purpose at
hand
for example to book a hotel room online
no one needs to know where i am from
and who my friends are and with our
proposal
we are offering an alternative to the
models
of the big online platforms because we
believe in a human centered digital
transition
ladies and gentlemen i wanted to mention
these examples
because they showcase our digital
ambition
this is about who we want to be as
europeans
and to capture this better we will
formulate a set of digital principles
such as access for all to the internet
a secure online space
the right to learn digital skills
algorithms that respect people
and the protection of children online
these important principles will
complement the legal rights
that already protect europeans online
like for example the protection of
personal data
or the freedom of expression
just three weeks ago we launched a wide
consultation on these digital principles
we want to listen to as many views as
possible from citizens
civil society businesses and
administrations
we then want to enshrine these
principles
in a solemn declaration by the european
parliament
the council and the commission
europe's digital principles shall guide
our actions and initiatives
i already mentioned digital identity
another example is artificial
intelligence
just a few weeks ago we proposed our new
legal framework
on ai it is the first
such framework worldwide
it puts the individual at the center
and it will ensure that people safety
and fundamental rights are protected
ai is yet another example of our
ambition we embrace
new technologies but we stand by our
values
by setting new standards for our single
market
and by inviting others around the globe
to follow
and that's why i am glad to see
that more and more private companies are
already using technology
for the better europe wants to match
digital progress with responsibility
dear prime minister kosta i know that
you are a strong ally in our digital
ambition
i'm grateful that the portuguese
presidency
has made the fair and inclusive
transition
a priority today you contribute to the
debate with the lisbon declaration
with it you call on european union
governments
to commit to a digital transformation
that aims to strengthen the human
dimension
and as the declaration rightly points
out
we must ensure that the digital
transformation
of our democracies has a purpose
and that no one is left behind
and i know that also the european
parliament is very engaged
in promoting our values and principles
in the digital space
since the early days of the pandemic the
parliament has
the essential role of access to the
internet for
all because it allowed europeans to
continue
learning working and communicating
during lockdown
so i am very pleased to see that our
objectives
are very much aligned
and even beyond as we seek to set
standards
at the global level we sense a lot of
interest among our international
partners
and this is why i think we are
privileged
to have antonio guterres addressing
today's
digital assembly digital technologies
play a
key role in accelerating access to
knowledge and
education for equality and participation
and for economic growth and job creation
and in his recent road map to digital
corporation
antonio guterres asked all countries
to put human rights at the center
when making rules on digital
technologies
our european union initiative
on the digital principles is a
contribution to that
process
ladies and gentlemen i started my
intervention with a reference to
portugal's seafaring history
we depend much more on global trade than
ever before but what keeps our economies
going today are not just shipping routes
but also data flows
these need stable secure and speedy
infrastructures
to reach our connectivity targets we
will need
major investments next
generation eu our 750
billion recovery fund gives us a
once in a lifetime opportunity for that
but our digital leadership also depends
on strong connectivity with the rest of
the world
and that is why i'm glad that later this
morning you will inaugurate
ella link ellalink
is the new submarine cable that connects
europe with latin america the first
direct high-speed connection
between the two continents ellalink
means even more to us
it will be a digital highway for joint
research and education
between europe and latin america it will
boost business scientific and cultural
exchanges
and overall it will help ensure the
security
the stability and the resilience of the
global open
internet on which our economies and
societies depend
ladies and gentlemen ella link is
more than a cable it symbolizes
our renewed partnership with latin
america
this sets an example for our engagements
with partners around the world
for our digital decade to be successful
we need to build more strong
international
digital partnerships first and foremost
with the united states
with whom we want to set up a
transatlantic trade and technology
council
but also with other partners such as
india europe and india just
launched a new connectivity partnership
at our summit in porto
a few weeks ago the european union will
work
hard to lead the way towards a
wide open coalition of partners around
the world
ladies and gentlemen as we embark on the
digital transition
we europeans are guided by our ambition
we are determined to live up to our
principles at home
and on the international scene our
digital
compass shows us the way the work on our
digital principles has
kicked off today's lisbon declaration
provides tailwind so do the valuable
contributions by the european parliament
and the united nations as europeans
we want to be the global leader of a
digital transformation
that puts people at its heart
you can count on europe i wish you
a very successful digital assembly
thank you for your attention